hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in book 4 of
Plato's Republic he's going to provide
us with an argument for there being what
he terms parts of the soul or suka the
word of course that we get psychology
from and this is often called Plato's
tripartite psychology or his faculty
psychology and we're really looking here
we're interested primarily in the way
that he argues towards saying that
there's three main parts of the soul and
there's a couple different approaches
that he's going to take in this section
he's kind of moving at it from different
angles the first thing that he talks
about is the soul having three forms of
virtue within it wisdom courage and
temperance being those and he's basing
this on the idea that the soul is going
to have the same elements as the larger
city that the soul you know is a person
within has as well and putting aside
those three virtues for a minute there's
there something that he says here says a
just person will not differ at all from
a just city in respect of the very form
of justice but will be like it so in
Plato's metaphysics as we know there are
these things that we call forms or
ideas and they're out in an intelligible
world we grasp them with our minds we
refer to them and we rely upon them to
make sense out of similar things so
justice is a quality within the soul
it's also a quality within the city and
those qualities are you know copies of
the form they're not exactly the same
justice and me isn't exactly the same as
justice in you and you know might be
kind of weaken me or you know tarnished
or not entirely there and it might be
better in you or vice versa but they're
all copies of that that thing out there
that we call the form let's say you
reject that let's say you're not
convinced of Plato's doctrine of the
forms Plato has another good argument
here and he says listen the city is
composed of the individual people who
are its citizens you're not going to
have temperance within the city without
having temperate citizens and what does
it mean to be a temper citizen it means
to have temperance within you as a
virtue and so presumably these three
very important virtues that have been
identified as belonging to the
particular classes or elements of the
city wisdom for the rulers courage for
the guard for the lesser guardians or
auxiliaries and temperance for everybody
but particularly the craftspeople since
they have the most opportunity to be
intemperate these are also going to be
within the soul and if you know that's
not a bad argument but it doesn't
actually get us three parts of the soul
necessarily here and so Socrates goes on
and he provides another argument that's
quite interesting here he says the
matter begins to be more difficult when
you ask whether we do all these things
all the things that we do with with our
being with the same thing or whether
there are three things and we do one
thing with one and one with another so
does the soul have different things or
parts or functions that we do different
things with
what would be the prime examples here
well he tells us maybe we learn with one
part of ourselves maybe we feel anger
translating it properly feel thumos with
another and with the third desire the
pleasures of nutrition and generation
and their kind nutrition is eating
generations having sex right and we can
think of other pleasures as well so do
we have a part that does the thinking
the learning all that and then a part
that gets riled up is another great way
of translating through most and a part
that desires
you know creature comforts and things
that we've we've learned to become
attracted to does the soul
use those parts to do those things that
are those are the functions of those
parts of the soul or does the soul as a
whole do all these things and so
Socrates here brings in a consideration
which is you know in some respects not
just metaphysical balada chol and he
says let's attempt to define the
boundary it's obvious the same thing
we'll never do or suffer opposites in
the same respect in relation to the same
thing and at the same time what do we
have there law of non-contradiction
right and expressed in a very good way
sometimes people are like you can't have
a and not a at the same time well
sometimes you can that's why we have to
have in the same respect and in
orientation to the same thing right I
can be angry at one person and yet
loving to another person if we think
those are opposites in some way at the
same time right but it's different
people so Socrates is saying when we
find a contradiction like that an
opposition we know we must be dealing
with two different and distinguishable
things so he says we'll know it's not
the same thing functioning but a
plurality so and he says you know let's
consider a few cases can the same thing
be in rest and that motion he says now
let's put aside stuff about tops where
the center of the top is
not in motion seemingly and the outside
of the top is in motion actually the top
is the center of the top is in motion -
it's just spinning in a circle smaller
circle as well when we look at the sole
some examples that he has that are quite
nice here he says will you not sit down
as opposed to one another ascent and
descent and the endeavour after a thing
- rejection of it embracing - repelling
do not all these and things like these
belong to the cut the class of opposite
actions or passions they are in fact
opposites to each other so you know when
for example the mind or the rational
part is accenting to something it's not
going to dis sent to that same thing in
the same way etc etc right same thing
with with deciding that we ought to go
after it literally to try to get it or
rejecting it or embracing things or
repelling them and we don't think it too
hung up on the terminology here the
point is when there's opposites within a
particular function it's only going to
be doing one or the other of those at
the same time so what is the upshot of
this well we can think about certain
desires he says shall we say the desires
constitute a class meaning appetites
when he says desires and the most
conspicuous members of that class or
what we call thirst and hunger we could
also put sexual appetite in there as
well or you know the appetite to lay
around and do nothing all day might fit
in there and he goes on and he talks
about you know distinctions that we can
make and quantity and goodness with all
of us and then he talks about the
sciences or forms of knowledge this is
all sort of rehearsal getting us ready
to see a fundamental bifurcation within
the human soul and what's the dividing
line between then he says okay let's go
back to thirst will you class it with
the things that are some that are of
something and say it is what it is in
relation to something
and you know if drink is of a certain
kind so is the thirst but thirst that is
just thirst is neither a mantra little
owner good or bad etc etc the soul of
the thirsty insofar as a thirst wishes
nothing else than to drink and yearns
for this and it's impulse is towards
this now why is he doing all of that
well we want to just consider thirst as
a type of appetite of desire on its own
are there times where we feel thirst and
we really do you know part of our soul
saying go get that that drink of water
right there and we keep ourselves from
doing it we maybe say this is not the
right time for me to go to the drinking
fountain and get a drink I need to keep
working over here or I've already had
some water I'm still thirsty but it
would be bad for me to drink the water
at this time because I should you know
allow the water that I've got to get
into my system whatever it happens to be
and the answer is yes there's another
part of our self that says don't drink
the water so he says right here if
anything draws it back when thirsty this
must be something different from that
which thirsts what is the thing that
thirsts the what we call the appetite
the appetite apart epithelia in greek so
he says that which thirst and drives it
like a beast to drink we cannot it
cannot be we say that the same thing
with the same part of itself at the same
time acts in opposite ways about the
same thing so we have in this very
simple example is one part saying get
the water get the water drink it up and
then the other part saying no no don't
do that one part is pushing us one part
is saying no to that and pulling us away
those must be different parts because
the same one single thing doesn't have
this capacity to to tell us different
things at the same time with respect to
the same object in the same way so we
have two parts what are those two parts
the appetite of epitome otic
part the part that has all these desires
you know eat drink have sex do all sorts
of other things that feel good
avoid things that feel bad and then the
rational part the part that does the
thinking the part that says you know I
know you don't like to exercise and
you've already walked a mile and you're
kind of huffing and puffing and tired
but why don't you keep going some more
because that would be good for your body
and your cardiovascular system because
we don't want to die young that the
apathetic part doesn't do that the
appetite apart just follows what feels
good and avoids what feels bad the
rational part is the part that keeps us
safe by saying here's the plan here's
what we want to do and it can oppose
it's off to desire sometimes it loses
sometimes it wins
kind of depends on how you condition
those parts so so far so good we've got
two parts to the soul now right two
different things going on so he says not
unreasonably we shall claim that there's
two and different from each other
naming in the in the soul where that
whereby it reckons and reasons the
rational and that with which it loves
hungers thurston feels the flutter until
a ssin of other desires wonderful phrase
there the irrational and appetite of
companion of various repletion z' and
pleasures now is that all for the story
some faculty psychologists do have that
there's a rational part in an irrational
part the Platonic tripartite psychology
I mean the word tripartite kind of gives
it away doesn't it says that there's
three parts to the soul and that there's
a second irrational part to the soul in
addition to the appetite of part how do
you get that same way so he says these
two forms a suit let us assume have been
marked off but what about the thumos
this part of us that we feel courage in
that we get angry with the principal of
high spirit or passion as it's often
translated by the way there is no good
translation in English of themost we
just have to stick with what we've got
right and understand what's being said
he says it
this a third part or it would it be
identical with one of these if it was
gonna be identical it sure wouldn't be
with the rational part because are you
rational when you're angry I mean you
think that you are but you're not
is it identical then with the appetite
of the irrational part no it's a
separate irrational part how do you know
so he gives one example here but we
could come up with many others he talks
about this guy Lee anteus who is on his
way from the Piraeus this port under the
outer side of the northern wall becoming
aware of dead bodies that lay at the
place of public education at the same
time felt a desire to see them his eyes
you know he has this desire to look at
the corpses and you had a repugnance or
aversion and for a time he resisted and
veiled his head but overpowered and
despite by all of all by his desire with
wide steering eyes he rushed up to the
corpses and cried to his eyes there hear
h's take your fill of the fine spectacle
he's ticked off with himself he's angry
with his eyeballs which is really you
know an extension of his the appetite a
part of his soul in this case for
wanting to look at the gross dead
corpses so in that case in other cases
too where sumos can make us do something
different than what the desires want
like when we do get angry say with other
people and we do risky stuff that our
desires say don't do or things that are
painful for us we have a conflict
between two fundamental types of desire
through most and epithelia passion or
spirited pardon in English is how we
translate it and the appetite apart so
now we know that we have three different
distinct parts to the soul and where's
Plato going to go from from here he is
going to associate these different
virtues with the different parts of the
soul but we don't have to go into that
here because we're primarily just
looking at how does he get there to be
three parts altogether this is the
argument that he provides
you